let us keep this civilized
welcome to the party
this will be over real quick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop this
[Music]
the crowd goes wild
[Music]
let there be fire
[Music]
well it's been a blast or it will be
[Applause]
and joining me from unknown worlds is
charlie cleveland charlie moonbreaker
it's real and it's
so different than subnautica so yes it
is this departure uh you guys like to
kind of reinvent yourselves every game
right yeah so people thought we were
kind of crazy for making subnautica
after making natural selection we went
from a strategy shooter to a pacifist
underwater game survival
so i feel like we've done this before we
you know we love changing genres but i'm
hoping you know our subnautica fans will
still come along for playing a digital
miniatures game i hope it's so cool a
digital miniatures game uh everyone
loves miniatures but how do you
translate that into gameplay what is the
gameplay of this game so uh we're kind
of channeling like uh guardians of the
galaxy or firefly kind of feel
so you can see that from the colorful
art style we have um so you choose a
captain and ten crew and you build a
roster kind of like a traditional
miniatures game and every unit in the
game is really
like strange and special and kind of
game breaking
so um
yeah you deploy units and you move them
around on the battlefield and you get
all these crazy game-changing powers
kind of like hearthstone meets x-com
kinda
well it i love i mean you see the
gameplay here it looks great and uh it's
coming soon as we said uh in the
september so you're not really actually
not going to wait long but the thing i
want to get to is the painting of
miniatures which we saw teas of in the
trailer and i know you actually painting
was cathartic for you sort of during the
pandemic right yeah so the painting i
mean you can't have a miniatures game
without painting and during the lockdown
i just found myself like learning to
draw and just like just zoning out and
feeling really relaxed when the world
was basically falling apart around us
and we really tried to capture that
feeling it's not like photoshop or like
special technical tools or anything like
that
we just simulate washes dry brushing
we've got decals
this feels like you're actually painting
a real miniature and i have to say
because everyone's surprised by it like
all the miniatures you see painted in
the game are all painted with the tool
so it's like actually pretty powerful
amazing well it's so cool that uh you're
revealing it here and it's gonna it's
playable at gamescom right it is it's
here you guys are the first ones to play
it wow and uh oh yeah it's more
we're over in the crafton booth okay
crafton booth and for everyone else
around the world yes long right yes
we'll be on steam play test in september
we have a couple open weekends and then
we're going to be launching um into
steam early access september 29th so
it's really close only a month away moon
breaker charlie thank you so much for
tuning in all the way out here thank you
i know you had a tough pleasure thank
you everyone all right charlie cleveland
with unknown worlds thank you so much
charlie